[Music]
my name is Julian Polanco I'm a national
master from the state of Missouri and
today we'll continue with part two of
our boring repertoire with the black
pieces too last week we covered or
rather less last time there's been many
weeks in between but the the night you
know the next video and chess opening is
explained we'll be covering efore last
last time I saw you you guys we were
covering d4 and it was the a6 love that
was my recommendation against pawn to d4
and this week we will be covering the
caro-kann which starts after Pawnee for
pawn c6 so what's the idea of the
caro-kann now in in chess against the
first move pawn to e4 they're basically
two different types of Defense's the
first type of defense is where you just
let the pawn on e4 beat and you try to
take control of other maybe key central
squares those moves would be something
like pawn to e5 or pawn to c5 very
viable and good good moves that are
played at the top level and the other
type of defense which instead of instead
of trying to go for the fair share of
the center right away tries to put a
media pressure on the e4 pawn those
would be maybe the Alekhine's defense
the French or the Scandinavian but those
all have their pluses and minuses but
basically the move pawn to c6 is trying
to challenge the move e to e4 because
after if white tries to get a perfect
center with d2 d4 black will play D 75
and he at
the e4 pawn so now white hat will have
to make a decision before we go into the
main lines we can discuss some sidelines
some people play this move d2 d3 which
contains a little bit more venom than
maybe some people would give credit for
i will reconcile recommend the move pawn
to d5 Knight d2 is the main line and
here g6 the main line here is to play e5
and this is also very fine I personally
don't like the positions arising after
Knight to f3 Bishop d6 and the move pawn
d3 to d4 I think white has a lot of
unnecessary play here I think g6 is very
solid and and we don't need to go for
any of these complications if if you are
player with the white pieces however I
would I would encourage you to look at
these lines because especially for blitz
because if black if black goes wrong
which I did against Nicholas Rosenthal
and some quick tournament here at the
club and plays eat 84 which is fine
Bishop d3 in here I'm playing the move D
takes d4 white already has a very
dangerous initiative Knight takes e4
Bishop before c3 takes castles and yeah
white way does very easy play for the
minuscule I'm not a material that he's
sacrificed so that's why I'll recommend
the move g6 here white will continue
with Knight f3 Bishop g7 g3 and now the
move pawn to e5 so we have a center here
we have more space with black which is
nice we want to continue our development
with 97 and potentially play the move f5
so Bishop g2 97 castles and if if white
isn't careful then black could just
steam steamroll white by expanding in
the center black has a lot of play here
White's position is very compact and
play is is roughly balanced what most
people will do here is play the move
rook e1 their idea would be to
if black made some stupid move like a
six to take on d5 and now black would be
forced to recapture was something that
he wouldn't want to but also it isn't
good anyway so Queen takes might look
like it defends the pawn on e5 but
Knight takes e5 would unleash a
discovered attack against the Queen so
why it would just be up a pawn for free
so black needs to react to this the best
way to do that is to play the move pawn
to d4 now at first sight this might look
like a very bad move because White has
the move Knight c4 which attacks the
pawn on e5 which isn't very easy to
defend if you play the move f7 to f6
which was just fine
the the main the main thing is you're
weakening your light squares and maybe
you white can consume with a4 and try to
claim he's achieve something because
usually when you play these f6 setups
it's not really good to have you ever
ship on g7 it doesn't do a whole lot
over there you would rather have your
Bishop on c7 where maybe it would
contribute to the Kings side so this
this would not be ideal but black has a
tactical opportunity here so for those
of you at home I would encourage you to
pause your video for a second and see if
you could find the best continuation for
black hopefully you did that and now
Claudio you know the answer what yeah b5
and the point is yeah the the point the
point of this move is it attacks the
knight and if the knight takes on e5 now
we can play off 6 and the Knights
actually trapped and actually this
position isn't so bad for white it's not
as bad as it would it would appear but
it is I mean black is better and I mean
white will get two pawns for the piece
but you know black is certainly better
out of the opening which is not anything
you should complain about so white would
if I wanted to continue here he would
play something like 92 but black is also
better here so
overall if you get this position then
you've already achieved success out of
the opening
so that should fairly extensively cover
the move d2 to d3 we can look at a game
between Rishabh off and chip arena
efore c6 so we get to our starting
position black plays d5 and here white
played the move b4 so what does this
move before why doesn't play the move
rook e1 because he doesn't want he
doesn't necessarily want blacks to go
for that variation with d4 so he wants
to maybe develop his Bishop to b2 and
maybe maybe expand later with the move
b5 and he's kind of preventing some
ideas with c5 in the future before is is
an interesting move but what what would
you do here with the black pieces
yeah Claudia wants to play a five why do
you want to play a five yeah
so what Claudio has mentioned is that
white cannot play the move a 2 2 a 3
which would be desirable in this type of
position because if black takes on
before and white takes him before the
rook on any one is hanging and if white
doesn't do that if you plays a move like
C 3 or B takes a 5 then he's compromised
to structure a little bit so black took
on a white took on a 5 Queen a 5 and
Bishop b2
why does claiming that though he has
compromised the structure he in return
for that has dynamic possibilities
against the pawn on e5 and wants to
force some kind of concession d4 Knight
B 3 Queen c7 C 3 so White's trying to
chip away at the center and and
pressured the e5 pawn but just take and
go C 5 and in this type of position we
would be controlling the d4 square it's
it's really hard to play white in these
types of positions play might continue
as in the game night ft 2 and b5
you don't have to play b5 it's also
possible just to play something like her
da and b6 Bishop d7 kind of slow play it
for all the positional Trump's but
anyway this is this was a clear success
out of the opening for black black
stands fine if you'd like to continue
looking at this game this is the game
we're a job off against chip chipper
enough caro-kann can look it up on chess
games early chess all linked to this
study after the lectures over so let's
let's continue we have a lot of material
to cover
hopefully that covers the move deep d3
sorry d2 d3 now another side line which
is very popular against the French is
of b-two b-three this is the only other
sideline that doesn't involve 93a of
some sort so the best way to react to
this this is slightly inferior usually
if you're gonna play b3 against against
any opening should be the French because
at least against the against the French
black doesn't have the option of
developing as Bishop to f5 so here we
should take on e4 you know the way to
refute okay we should go d5 after b3
attacking the center Y does not advise
to play e5 this is an extremely dubious
version of the of the advanced variation
and taking on d5 obviously doesn't
doesn't bring white any any advantages
over the normal exchange variation so
white will play Bishop b2 in this
position take Knight c3 Knight f6
protecting me for Knight 92 is the best
move if you play Queen e2 then Bishop f5
is just good for black so and the same
can be said for for 90 to 93 but at the
very least y can get his pawn back
because now he has queenie to e6 takes
97 h4 queen a5 which is funny because
it's kind of we're kind of we kind of
want to play Bishop a3 which is
something that you might see in the
Sicilian dragon but anyway a4 to stop
Bishop a3 Bishop e7 and here the
position is equal so this is this is how
I would recommend handling the black
pieces against b3 so let's let's
continue hopefully that was that was
what you were looking for okay so the
next the next side line
against the caro-kann is the exchange
variation so when black plays to move d7
b5 challenging the center Y can react in
one of three ways he can take he can
push or he can defend it now taking is
is probably the least critical because
this releases the tension and now
something interesting has happened well
white is essentially done he hasn't
traded the e4 pawn for the d5 pawn he's
traded the e4 pawn for the c6 point
that's what's happened so now black has
two pawns in the center and white has
only one so this could be considered
some kind of achievement this is a kind
of a reversed Queens gambit declined
structure so if if white word to play
nonchalantly like let's say to move c2
c3 right then black could have the
potential plan of the minority attack
let's let's just put some moves on the
board the minority attack with some kind
of rook b8 b b5 before so this if white
doesn't play aggressively then black
black can achieve very easy play you can
develop your pieces first of course like
this make some decision a rook e1
something like this but black would be
slightly better in this type of position
so this would be nothing to feel so
white white really shouldn't be playing
like this the most aggressive move here
is the move c2 to c4 which would be the
pan of attack which is a very decent
reply to the Cairo as in it's trying to
take the opening head-on however I don't
I don't know with on if I mean I don't
think it's the most critical approach
but it is more critical than than doing
anything else other moves the main move
here if you're not going to play c4 is
Bishop d3 if white were to play Knight
to f3 then black would
eventually play the move Bishop to g4 so
why it tries to avoid that for as long
as possible and if you don't play the
move Knight to f3 then blacks
other good square for the bishop is on
f5 this kind of structure that that we
got in last week's opening so here
Bishop d3 is played to avoid Bishop f5
now you can do one of two things and
both are fine I slightly prefer the more
accurate way to play but my I used to
have a pet line against this variation
which was 96 I would always play because
it practically forced the move c3 why
doesn't want to play Knight up there
because of their ship g4 9 f6 is it used
to be my pet line and I'll show you some
ideas Bishop f4 everybody would play B
well you'll see why in in a second but
the bishop is very useful and on f4 it
controls a lot of squares and you can
get this position from the London system
too actually but anyway I would play the
move g6 Knight of 3 Bishop g7 castles
castles 92 and here is where I would
surprise most of my opponents I would
play the move Bishop to f5 anyway it's
like well what are you doing I play the
move Bishop d3 to kind of deter you from
playing Bishop f5 but in this type of
position I was very happy to get this
structure and I got this in a lot of
games actually against lower rate of
players and I I would just I'll play
them because I knew the plans and ideas
in general black Black gets to put his
94 which is very nice there will be some
minority attack with b5 before maybe you
can attack on the G file with key
nightshade and rook g8 now this isn't
all all good for black black has
weakened the structure if Y can achieve
at some moment h3g for this could be
very strong if he can somehow create
some weakness on the Queen side then
that would
for him this is a very concrete position
which which deserves some analysis but
White's White's best move is to play 95
trying to trying to create a weakness on
c6 e six or sorry yeah so immediately
you can't take on c6 because black will
just be in time to get rid of it with c5
but here black moves now to play an edge
e6 and this is very viable and if you
want an easy kind of plan to remember I
would highly recommend the system with
black I think that against the majority
of players you will even get better
positions out of the opening just
because if you analyze these positions
enough you'll have the advantage that
nobody's ever studied this position
which is something that I've I've
encountered now that being said blacks
probably only equal there and black can
actually get an advantage in this
opening after c3 the best move is Queen
to c7 to prevent the move Bishop f4
white plays Knight e2 to play Bishop f4
and here here a 5 is very possible
trying to get an isolated pawn structure
which you'll get anyway but better is
actually to play the move Bishop g4 and
if f3 now you play Bishop d7 Bishop f4
and E 5 and we've provoked this weakness
f2 to f3 obviously if you play the move
Bishop f4 now that this this Bishop has
an ion on the d1 square both I believe
both Queen f4 and Bishop e2 offer black
better position so so here white would
play the move f2 f3 breaking the pin and
then you would go Bishop d7 and after
Bishop f4 attacking the Queen you go u5
and this pin is very temporary if you
take Knight takes castles Bishop d6 you
break the pin and you play Knight to e7
and black has black has a lot of plans
in this position and stands probably
slightly better so this is the the main
system I would recommend against the
change although also here after 92 it
should be mentioned that ie 5 is very
possible and equalizes as well d takes
knight takes Bishop e5 Bishop d7 take
take and though this this is an isolated
pawn position so black just develops his
pieces sorry
Oh white plays Bishop g5 why black has
this interesting move here Queen in g4
and this equalizes I'm attacking g5 and
I have a clear view of the a Foursquare
anyway I would recommend playing playing
the move Bishop g4 that's just my
preference if you don't like that I
would recommend playing the move Knight
at night f6 in this position and then
going for g6 Bishop f5 but also
interesting although I personally
wouldn't play it is to play e5 before
playing Bishop g4 that kind of covers
the exchange variation so now let's move
on to the panel which is semi serious so
the main problem you will have with
black in this position now granted you
will not have this problem if you're
playing against higher rated opponent
who you do not mind drawing but the main
problem is that white can force a draw
and the absolute main line so I believe
you should play Knight of 693 96 and
here if white were to play the move
Knight to f3
I personally believe the best move is
Bishop to g4 but this line is a forced
draw that white can make which I
personally do not like or white will be
significantly better it's it's one of
the two and I and those those I'll show
the line in a second but the thing that
I really don't want to do here with
black is play the move east 76 because
now white white actually gets a pretty
dangerous attack the bishop on c8 isn't
going to really play in this type of
position and these positions were never
to my taste with black I mean white will
probably get an isolated pawn but at the
same time white gets a dangerous attack
well as some initiative there are lots
of games here basically this is
something
that I would I would aim to avoid with
the black pieces knight c6 is best after
93 the ship g5 is the main move but a
side line here is Knight to f3 and I'll
show the force draw line which you would
not mind playing against a higher rate
of player but that would start with
Bishop c4 takes Knight takes Queen b3
and here the best move is Bishop takes
f3 takes c6 and now why does the the
option plane Quimby 7s sorry this is all
best Queen b7 takes and here in this
position white can make a draw with
Bishop b5 takes and Queen takes b5 is is
not better for white this type of ending
is is very very decent for black eye I
have won many games with with the black
pieces here you never really have
problems here but there's this move
Queen c6 which forces the move Queen oh
sorry King to e7
now here why can white sorry y can play
the move Queen to c5 which which looks
really weird because you've allowed the
night to go to d6 but actually after
96-95 takes castles is probably just
winning for white what's initiative is
is way too strong you can do further
analysis if you don't believe it but the
point is Queen c6 Keaney 7 white can
force a draw by playing Queen c5 Keaney
a queen c6 Keaney 7 and that's a draw
and okay drawing with the black pieces
and is so bad and it's it's good to keep
this line line in mind in case you're
preparing against somebody that you the
you know you would be very happy making
a draw with but it's never been to my
tastes so recently I've made an
adjustment in my opening repertoire so I
started playing the move Bishop to e6
which I think offers black a lot of
decent counter chances
and probably is is a better a better
move if you're trying to play for a win
so last week I believe Claudio you you
you were talking about 995 right as
something like this so yeah yeah so 9 85
was is is the most critical way to to
deal with the move Bishop e6 it just
happens not to be very good here because
of the DC 4 is a very bad move because
I'm a 96 but here black has the move
Bishop g4 and if you play f3 then the
bishop goes all the way back to c8 and
the pawns on f3 which means the knight
cannot return there so Queen b3 after
Bishop g4 and now we can take on d4 it's
very important that you play Bishop g4
if you play Bishop f5 see takes Knight
takes Queen b3 this position is very
dangerous for black probably objectively
lost because after East 6 Queen d7 you
might notice that the the knight is
hanging but those of you with with eagle
eyes might also see that this is
checkmate which is hard to deal with
with black so the difference being that
when the bishops on g4 right and we go
for this variation now we can we can
take on d4 whereas in this line with
Bishop f5 Queen b3 here I believe I
believe
let's do some slate I'm sorry let's see
sorry in this position ah sir
takes the reason why Bishop f5 is bad
it's because they can take on d5
and if 95 then Quimby through ones so if
if the move Bishop and g4 is played then
Queen b3 Queen b3 is forced because the
Queen's hang so yeah that's that's
that's the reason for playing Bishop g4
but it's very important that you
remember the movie ships you for here
because otherwise why it would have more
than a decent position this is actually
good for black so Bishop g4 very
important but it does kind of refute
Knight g5 the best move here is to play
c5 I'm trying to grab space on the Queen
side and this type of position is
actually strategically winning for white
if he can you know like push his pawns
and make a queen right this is very
dangerous strategically but black in
these types of positions has sacrificed
you know his strategic advantage for
that of immediate counter play so here
after c5 I would recommend the move g6
to play ideas such as 90 for Bishop
she's having a b6 Bishop b5 Bishop g7 95
and here white has made an effort to
attack the C's the c6 Knight and this
Bishop isn't really doing a whole lot on
on e6 so we just moved back to d7 we're
threatening to kind of simplify with 95
in some positions but really here after
Bishop c6 Bishop c6 if I were to play
Knight c6 b c6 black would already stand
probably better because he's going to
achieve the movie 75 and see if I will
be a weakness at some point this Bishop
is going to be a monster in the future
so anyway Bishop d7 Bishop c6 castles
castles rook e1 a white White's not only
five is worth more than Bishop on c6 so
he doesn't he doesn't wish to trade it
quite yet but this is basically the end
of the opening and you you will face the
middle game with a lot of pluses one all
of your pieces are developed you will
have no problem there there are no
clear weaknesses in the position for
black after 96 BC 6 you could argue the
c6 bonus is a clear weakness but then
you have a definite plan of play Knight
d7 in b5 so overall this should achieve
equality for black and I'm very happy
recommending it for any aspiring Carroll
player so let's return to this position
Knight 96 and overall more critical
attempt is to play the move Bishop to g5
now here I used to play the line D take
c4 but then I got a little scared I I do
believe that after Bishop takes c4 that
white that black is perfectly fine in
this position because he has the move h6
which forces the bishop to one of two
diagonals
if the bishop goes to e3 right the
that's slightly more more irritating but
bishop h4 is actually a strategic
mistake here can anybody Claudia do you
know why you're pretty good at chess why
is Bishop h4 bad
Queen takes on deforesters are very
dangerous this is dangerous yeah
Queen 64 might equalize but it's it's
something that I would never play play
just because I mean queen bee 3 is also
possible and you take h4 bishop f7 it's
very dangerous
also Queen takes d4 Knight takes d4
castles Queen side it's also very
dangerous and if you return to c6 the
night b5 but no y is well wait wait what
are you talking about okay well the
reason why the bishop is is poorly
placed on h4 which if not a lot of you
got you don't have to feel so bad
because you know I I probably wouldn't
have wouldn't know this either if you
know I I had enough found this out from
stronger players and myself but
basically in these types of positions
for white why does only one good idea
and that is that eventually when we get
into an isolated Queen Queen pawn
structure what he'd really like to do
yeah is take on aged six yeah and this
is very dangerous
so why plays the move Bishop e3 then you
know like he's trying to attack and then
you have to you have to have some force
lines
yeah yeah that's that's that's that's
what you should do but basically I I
didn't stop playing this position
because of Bishop c4 because I do
believe that h6 does equalize but I
stopped playing it because after d5 95
there's this move Queen d4 the best move
here is h6
alright I'll just show you some line
says you don't have to try to memorize
this or anything
Bishop h4 and Bishop f4 transpose it's
after 9:00 to 6:00 the best moves Bishop
e3 e6 d6 and I really like playing this
position for awhile because if you just
look at it it looks like blacks lost
Black has only one good move here which
took people very long time to figure out
and that's a knight to e7 using the fact
that the Queen on d4 is is pinned for a
move so yeah the night's going to have
five the reason why I stopped liking
this position I think I remember so
castles was the thing that was causing
me some problems and this position is
not at all clear I'm not sure black is
doing okay black as when does a very
dangerous initiative so like like s has
to be very careful so Queen d2 tonight
at Queen d2 is also interesting but yeah
okay
so we'll say h6 Bishop h4 Knight g6
Bishop g3e 6d 697 the most dangerous
thing here is probably just castling
queenside and this was giving me some
headache I will not recommend this
variation so keeping in the theme of our
other panel flying after Bishop to g5 I
will recommend recommend the move Bishop
to e6 a3 is best because if you if you
play that move Knight to f3 here since
the bishops placed on g5 94 is actually
very annoying
if a3 sorry a3 is trying to prevent in
the future some night before and also it
prepares the idea of playing c5 and now
that what with the knight on c6
you would not be able to meet b6 with
before but now you can
so a3 is a very useful move in the main
line here if I were to try Knight f3 g6
Bishop f6 EF c5 Bishop g7 there should
be five castles castles g4 takes takes
would be better for black so after
Bishop e6 a3 Queen d7 because we want to
play rook d8 and put a media pressure on
the D pawn
there should be two rook da now white
should take on f6 if you if you play the
move C 594 is is already much better for
black so Bishop f6 is kind of mandatory
and here i takes
c5 g6 Queen d2 the reason why Queen d2
is played is because if you allow black
to move Bishop h6 then he stands very
well so that's why black plays h5 black
wants to play the move Bishop Bishop to
h6 but now f4 f4 kind of makes the
bishop look stupid on age sex which is
good but if Y were to play a move like
Knight to f3 for example Bishop h6 would
already be very good for black the
diagonal is uncontested and white white
is serious problems on the dark squares
so g6 Queen d2 h5 f for trying to blunt
the bishop on the h6 to see one diagonal
Bishop g7 out of three castles castles
rook rook f e8 rook e1 and black should
be black should be fine I believe
there's some Apollo flight Go game here
let me just see if I'm correct so here
actually after Bishop f6 aleyko took
with the Jeep on which is also very
possible
g3 castles Queen side and this was a
very interesting game also you should
take a look at this but basically my
recommendation against all pan off lines
is to play a setup with Knight f6 Knight
c6 and then put your Bishop from CA to
e6 and then develop the F a bishop via
the g7 to a one diagonal
all right so let's move on to our next
sideline which which has become more and
more popular in recent years and that
that being the two Knights variation of
the CARICOM so this is we're actually
sorry I should I should mention a few
other side lines first
so after d5 why does the option of
playing Queen f3 which forces a better
version of setups that you wouldn't
necessarily play against the classical
variation here the best line is to take
on e4 94 and you have the the option of
playing the move Knight to f6 this is
very possible and taking either way
because the Queen's kind of misplace in
these these types of positions this is
also very very possible for y but I
personally believe that 97 is the best
because here d4 Knight of 695 h6 just
refutes 95 so white should do something
else and if he does anything else then
you take on e4 and play Knight f6 and
you've already equalized that of the
opening the reason why people play queen
up 3 and this is something that you
should also remember is that lots of
black players play the move d5 to d4 and
Bishop c4 is very annoying and white
develops some initiative
I would not recommend this variation for
black so after the move Queen to f3 this
is one of the rare moments where I would
recommend maybe the Karpov like an
improved version of the car pop
variation with 97 or the Bronstein lines
with Knight f6 those are those are very
possible but the move Knight of three is
the best de to d4 is also possible that
just transposes to the classical so
Knight of three the ship g4 is what I
recommend what I which is which is kind
of strange because actually I almost
never played the move Bishop g4 and my
turn in practice most of the time when I
when I play the Carroll Khan and I've
reached the the two Knights several
times with black I've always played the
move Knight of 6 which I do believe
equal
there's nothing wrong with it but for a
more interesting play I think bishops
you for as probably but there's once
again nothing nothing wrong with Knight
f6 he five ninety four and after ninety
two Queen b6 which is very good in a one
minute game because maybe they'll now
slipped III deep for a six-night g1
trying to trap the night with f3 f6f-3
and takes f4 and both 94 94 Knight of 7
offer black a very decent equalizing
chances and this is something that if
you want to play with the black pieces I
would be very happy because it's
something that I I do personally with
black but you will have to do additional
study on your own instead I'll recommend
the move Bishop to g4 which is a little
bit more critical than I thought
previously and after h3 now the main
line here is Bishop takes f3 which I
hate with the passion I would never play
this variation with with with the black
pieces I think that after Bishop f3 you
get a very solid position granted and
maybe that's more in line with with our
discussion you can I would not hate you
if you would play this but in general I
really don't like the positions after
the move D 397 Bishop d2 g6g for the
this it seems like white as two bishops
for free and a very improve urchin of
some kind of Kings Indian attack
not to mention after East six the move
d4 which has played several times by new
Palma she should offer very good chances
for for an advantage for white so
overall I think Bishop f3 is wrong and
black should play Bishop h5 now this is
considered slightly dubious because it
takes takes but should be 5 most people
don't know this though so 95 this this
is like most people's knowledge ends
here and they're like well we assume
this is bad because everybody's always
told us that this is bad and they play
the move h4 and they're hoping for you
to play a stupid move like h h6 and then
we can get a horrible structure on g6
that's something that you never want by
the way this structure ff7 takes g6 if
you have to do that then you've you
failed out of the opening but that being
said this position is already better for
black in my opinion I believe that after
f6 black has zero problems and the vast
majority of the players who play this
variation with white will not know this
and you you you already have the
advantage out of the opening not
necessarily because you're better
although you might actually be better
but more to the point people will think
that they're better so they'll like over
push when they're not actually better
instead of realizing the situation isn't
so clear now the best move for white is
Queen e2 will return to that in a second
after h4 you should play f6
never play of six except in this
instance never play of six except when
you need to play of six 9 g 6h g queen
d3 attacking g6 pawn and here just king
f7 the kingdom is a very nice home on on
the f7 square where all these pawns are
kind of protecting it it's like it's its
castle but the rook is or is also
contributing to the h4 pawn that okay
this all is nice for black but it's also
maybe slightly weak on R so it's not
like a perfect situation
but anyway white really has to take on
c6 now because the night before has
suddenly become a threat rook takes c6
Bishop d2 Bishop b4 castles 97 and black
is
more than fine so what why should do in
this position and if you're a white
player then I would recommend playing
this way it's to play the move Queen to
e2 and after the and the mainline would
continue Bishop to b4 but this is a
piece sacrifice and I I don't I would
not recommend this but anyway here after
Queen e2 I would recommend the move
Bishop d6 now those are those of you who
are more advanced at home you might
notice that this looks strange because
now I can just went a pawn on d5 but I
actually believe that Black has very
good compensation here based on the fact
that white as has severely weakened his
King side and it's not really clear
where as Cain wants to live it's hard
for him to kind of go Queen side he's a
lot of moves and black can create
immediate counter play there was a game
between it I forget who is some let me
let me check some name I can't pronounce
and Dean Lee renting Leon was playing
with the black pieces and he won a very
nice game with black I will I will
insert this or not insert that's about
whatever I'll cite this so now any of
you who want to study this game you can
go to my study and you can click the
link anyway so that is my recommendation
against the two knights you have two
options I believe you can play Knight f6
94 that's a very good line
probably objectively best that equalizes
for sure lots of top games have gone
that way or you can play this may be
crazy / dubious line which involves a
pawn sack with Bishop to h5 and maybe
you're slightly worse but what really
has to know what he's doing not not to
not to become significantly worse so
that that's my recommendation for the
two knights let's move on to the fantasy
variation
now I recently lost a game to mark Parag
WA at the philadelphia international
after f3 i I used to always play this
movie 75 but I believe this is very
dangerous or sorry I would always take
and I would always take and plate you 75
and I believe this position is very
dangerous you have to know exactly what
you're doing I basically lost out of the
opening
yeah 9 of 3 is is very interesting in oh
I don't know maybe yeah it's yeah I'm
not saying this one is bad necessarily
I'm just saying that it's not my
preference maybe I don't know I don't
know what Claudio is referring to but
but I I like I like my recommendation
here better because so it's a funny
story actually
and I can't take all the credit for me
playing this variation but I was at
Philadelphia International and world
open and I was rooming with two friends
of mine
well one being Duncan Shepard and the
other being Dennis Norman and I just
lost this game to mark Drago and I was
pretty pretty upset because you know the
care was kind of like the only opening
that I that I play consistently I've
like switched around a lot and 1.d4 and
you know with the white piece I play
everything but the karo I've always kind
of played after I got to 2,200 so I
thought you know I should know what I'm
doing right but I just got destroyed I
was like what what just happened
right like Dee takes e4 and e5 and I was
like I lost out at the opening this is
like my favorite opening like I'm okay
if I lose in the middle gamer ending in
the Kara it's like I'm battered you
the endings and middle games but I'm
Kara the opening fine yeah I've done
that too but mostly mostly Carol and
tournament Joe's but anyway so Dennis
Dennis Duncan and I sat down and we were
like okay so and I was like okay I never
want to do that again I never want to
have to memorize like a whole bunch of
forcing lines that might lead to maybe a
slightly better position or a position
that might be slightly preferable for
black and I have to avoid all these like
landmines
what would involve me losing immediately
so instead we came up with this idea
playing g6 and the very next time I got
to play this in tournament because if
you're one of the players in the US and
I assume my opponent prepared for me
I played Alex bian and I won't show that
a game here but I actually beat Alex
being him he's he's not a bad player
he's like 2,400 USCF the very next time
I got this position with with with black
I played g6 and we played all these
moves you play 93 Bishop g7 there should
be 3 and this was this was my prep Queen
b6 Queen d2 I took on b2 rook be one
Queen a3 and here after takes Knight f6
takes is very important you remember
this you take with the be pawn and now
what what we've basically done is we've
transformed this Cairo into a very
grünfeld esque position where blacks
going to be fighting for the c-4 square
so blacks plans are very simple you
castle so why put Bishop c4 you develops
a piece Castle 92 and here you you play
Bishop basics trying to fight for the
c-4 square you want to trade the bishops
and eventually you want this night to go
here and if you can achieve that then
you'll be much better with the black
pieces and I and I actually won against
Alex being relatively quickly I'm not
sure I I definitely don't have time to
go over that game but it's very
interesting it might be in a database
somewhere anyway there are a whole bunch
of high-level games here and blacks
should equalize it's not necessarily
better than the mainland's of the
fantasy where black might be better and
if you're looking for an alternative to
this line
even though I've enjoyed success with
this it might not be to your taste you
can also play the movie 76 which is very
interesting so now I have to kind of go
through the main lines we've covered all
of the side lines
so here we're on two of the main lines
we might not get through all of them
this time around but we're gonna try
efore c6 d 4 D 5 92 or 93 it doesn't
matter really but the main difference is
between 92 and 93 is the 93 lots two
sidelines which 92 does not those being
a6 and g6 after 92 g6 is really stupid
because when the bishop arrives on g7
white will just play the move C 2 C 3
and it's biting on granite and a6 here
makes no sense the point of a six after
93 is that if white plays Knight of
three you can play Bishop g4 but after a
six white just plays c3 Bishop d3 and
waits for black to develop his bishop so
why it would be significantly better if
black does not just take on e4 which I
do recommend takes Bishop f5 is is is my
main recommendation although there is
something to be said for playing the
carp offline with 97 I believe yes or
Sarah one recommended that I play in
this fashion with black after 95 just
playing the move h6 which most people
would consider you know maybe a slight
mistake because why does this move 96
but I would just play the move Queen b6
now we are threatening to take the
knight we weren't on the previous move
because Queen h4 I would have been mate
in two so now we are threatening to take
the knight and William to be up a piece
but white will take on f8 and now Knight
takes f8 and the reason why I don't
really like this position with black is
I really like my bishops so III won't
part with them so easily
so white kind of has the two bishops for
free but this is very solid and you're
not going to lose in like five moves
here so I'm play play might continue
like night uh probably Knight f3 knight
c6 and well you're just going to develop
your pieces like that and cast
okay black is probably slightly worse
but the position never suited my suited
my style so I always publish about 593
Bishop g6 there are a few side lines
even here white can play something like
Knight h3 or 92 they probably just
transpose after Knight h3 you should go
east six night a for Bishop d6 c3 Knight
of 6 and if h4 take on f4 and just play
h6 and black is fine now the difference
between this position and the previous
one were I gave away the the bishop for
four seemingly nothing this looks like
the same is that black can get immediate
pressure against the b2 pawn and he's
slightly ahead in development as opposed
to the other line where the knight was
stuck on f8 so black has fewer problems
to solve and actually I'd rather be
black here so that's if they play Knight
h3 and if they put their night on e -
then you go E 5 takes takes takes 97 and
this gives black very good very good
compensation you shouldn't take on e6
that gives white something to target
nice e5 takes takes and Castle queenside
and black has excellent compensation for
one point so those are the two side
lines also I should mention 95 can be
well met by e5 and black is already
better a knight be 795 and take take
black is too active for white to do this
mmm Black has developed two pieces why
does develop none so going back here
sorry tonight HD right now we just
covered that right yeah night yeah yeah
yeah yeah no we covered both 93 92 bi
you alright so the main move here is to
play h4 which practically forces blacks
play h6 and now Knight f3 now I should
mention the black can play every legal
move here I mean not every legal mode
but you have three options not f6e six
and ninety-seven all of them are good my
my problem with playing Knight of 6 & e6
is not that those are bad moves it's
just I don't see the benefit of playing
that over the main line now the only
thing I can say is some people will be
maybe a little bit silly and they'll try
to refute a 6 right away with playing 95
and Queen h5 but the problem here is
that black just has Queen c7 and c2 is
hanging you're gonna play Knight of 6
the Queen's really misplaced on h5 the
queen is on c7 is very normal for this
opening so black black should stand
perfectly fine in this position but if
white plays like he normally does like
h5 and Bishop d3 in the main lines I
didn't see any benefit of playing the
move order with Knight of 6 or 97 I just
don't see the benefit but some nuance in
the opening now that could be just me
but I would recommend after Knight of 3
to just play them above 97 discouraging
95 because you went up on like this
alright so h5 Bishop h7 Bishop d3 takes
takes c6 Bishop d2 and here I would
recommend the lines with castles King
side which might surprise many of you
but I really hate I really hate the
castles Queen side lines with black I
think that if you're like 2650 and you
want to draw 2600 you can play those
lines you'll be slightly worse forever
and you might make a draw but I've never
I mean white is clearly better after
Queen c7 and castles Queen side he just
has more space and room for his pieces
the downside of playing Knight f6 and
Bishop e7 to Castle King
is that you are the the main problem is
that you're risking getting mated which
I mean I can understand the risk but if
you if you know your lines here you
should be fine there are two dangerous
moves here all others are kind of silly
those moves actually had some person
play Queen e2 against me at World Open
but I went in like ten moves so whatever
although he was like 2,200 but the main
was here are 94 in king b1 let's start
with 94 the old main line what you
should do is you should just take on you
for and if Knight f6 you go Queenie 200
white goes Queen e2 if if white plays
Queen d3 is very important that you just
Castle here because after Queen e2 Queen
d5 is possible but if the Queen's on d3
then Queen d5 is meant by c4 and Queen
b3 and black has serious problems out of
the opening so you have to remember that
when the Queen's on E - you play Queen
g5 c4 and Queenie 4 and black is already
equalized and Queen d3 you should Castle
white will play the move g4 now the
benefit for black of having the Queen on
d3 is that the Queen and you - is an
x-ray in the night so that would create
additional tactical opportunities so the
downside of playing Queen d3 is that if
what if black does Castle queenside I
start keen side then your attack isn't
as strong however if you played Queen to
e2 then we wouldn't have Castle kingside
in the first place so anyway Knight
takes g4 rook g1 this is what you should
do for a while I was playing the move
Queen to d5 but my main problem with
this is I wasn't entirely sure what the
evaluation of such a position would be
it's very unclear and okay I don't know
but anyway 94 is best rook g1 I have no
interest in playing Knight takes up too
yes f5 is is the best in 96 f2 is is not
not what I would recommend at all I have
no interest in playing this position it
just looks like too much compensation
for what for a mere exchange I mean the
night on do you want strapped it's a
rook but it's an exchange but anyway the
best is to play f5 Queen e2 and just
keen h8 a strong move and after Queen e6
Queen d6 and this position should be
perfectly fine for black if white trades
Queens and if white goes away somewhere
like Queen e2 then rook e8 and black has
all of his pieces developed and g7 is a
weakness but h5 is a weakness as well
the position is approximately balanced
so that covers Knight to e4 now the most
critical move is the move came to be one
now black castles is this is a waiting
move because now when ninety four
happens takes takes Knight of six Queen
goes to e to see in the previous
variation we were playing Queen d5
Queenie four as opposed to castles King
side so White's kind of tricked us into
castling and putting the Queen on you
two but this position is fine if you
just play Queen d5 there are two main
moves Bishop e3 and 9595 Queenie for
Bishop e3 95 rook h3 okay so it's it's
good to centralize the Queen and
actually this this Queen is very good on
the h7 to be one diagonal so after Rick
g4 we just play corner 7 and this
position is is equal and actually I'd
rather prefer I'd rather be black in
this type of position it's kind of easy
to attack White's Cain your ideas to go
like c5 and you know like pawn storm on
that side and black is already like the
queen turn h7 both both defends the
Kings side and it puts pressure on the
Queen side so it's a very good piece so
that's that's 95 and if and if Bishop to
e3 then Queen b5 is best c4 queen of
five c5 Knight age for Queen h7 I gave
an exclamation point because you know
it's the Queen on h7 as proven by alpha
zero as always as always a good piece
just kidding d5 takes takes rook da
Bishop h6 rook
a bishop goes back Queenie for and black
stands perfectly fine in this ending all
right so hopefully that's that's the
main that's that covers the classical
variation the only thing left are the
two advanced variations but I but I
believe I will go over that next time
because well the advanced variation is
is is the one that might refute the
caro-kann and you do need to know a lot
about the positions just just to survive
them so this is I believe that if your
opponents don't play the advanced then
the karo is a very good opening and
equalizes alma almost effortlessly but
after e5 you you will have you will need
to do a serious opening work to it to
equalize so thank you very much this was
Julian politico on the CARICOM
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]